late last week way out in the Nevada
BlackRock desert the high Priests of
Burning Man ignited a 26 foot tall
13-foot wide altar which burned for 20
minutes before collapsing to reveal a
giant steel Idol of a phoenix which
according to aforementioned High priests
supposedly had something to do with
Ukraine
then the entire place got flooded
an unexpected and highly unusual storm
appeared right over the festival dumping
three to four months worth of rain at
least on the desert
the total rainfall is estimated as
having been between half an inch and a
full inch doesn't necessarily sound like
a lot but we're talking about the desert
so to put that in perspective
just a fifth of an inch was expected for
the entire month of September
as a result seventy thousand people have
been trapped in the mud for days with
attendees being told to conserve food
and water which are apparently in short
supply
now
I don't want to read too much into it
but
as a general rule it seems to me that
one should avoid traveling to the desert
for week-long bacchanalian orgies that
culminate in the worship of giant
burning idols
it never turns out well
whatever The Burning Man people are
seeking whether it be but all Thrills
like drugs and weird sex or the more
esoteric spiritual stuff to which those
sensual Pleasures point
is not going to make them happy
they are not going to find what they are
looking for
because eventually the music is going to
end and the drugs are going to wear off
and the sex is going to reach its Climax
and the people who place their hope in
dead Idols are going to find themselves
still unsatisfied hungry thirsty
and covered in filth I'm Michael
knowlesis the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers okay
great meet at a secure price and 30
bucks off your order with my code
Knowles Canada w-les just had a juicy
good Rancher's rib eye and it was
magnificent as always go to go
ranchers.com use code Knowles today the
libs are going to do covet again they're
already in the process of doing covet
again the last kovid was begun in the
year before the 2020 presidential
election now we're the year before the
2024 presidential election and they are
doing
covid but it's a little different this
time and Dr fauci's facing some heat
we'll get to it in a second first though
speaking of looking for happiness in all
the wrong places there's a woman who's
gone totally viral and she's just a
random woman no one's ever heard of her
before she posts a lot of content on
social media so she clearly wants to be
a public person but until this weekend
she had been a private person and I
think it was Walsh actually I think it
was Matt who discovered This Woman's
Tick Tock and made her go viral she's
gone viral for explaining how happy she
is not to be married and not to have
children because she gets to sleep in
late and drink too much and go to
concerts and things like that and she's
going viral because while her words say
that she's very happy her eyes and her
demeanor and the tone of her voice tell
a different story
it's 10 45 a.m on a Saturday I'm 29 and
single and I don't have kids yet here's
what your Saturday morning looks like
when you're single at 29 and you don't
have a kid running around the house I
didn't rise from my bed until 10 15.
every time I thought I should probably
get up and do something I thought why
nobody's making me I'm not missing out
on anything I went to Beyonce last night
and I didn't get home until 1am and I
danced and drank my little heart out and
I didn't pay a babysitter to watch my
kids as I did that and I woke up a tad
hungover this morning which is probably
why I was in bed for so long and I was
just scrolling on my phone and I saw a
picture of Shaq Shuka and I thought you
know what sounds really good maybe I'm
gonna learn how to make shakshuka today
this woman had my total sympathy a lot
of conservatives watched this and
reacted with scorn and derision she had
my total sympathy until she mentioned
shakshuka which is disgusting shaku
Shuka is this breakfast dish where you
you poach eggs in a spaghetti sauce and
it's just gross and poached eggs are
fine I like poached eggs and spaghetti
sauce I like very much of course and all
sorts of different dishes but you put
those two things together it's gross I
like veal salt in Boca I like green
Jolly Ranchers I don't want to put them
together so anyway that's where she
really started to lose me and and her
monologue went downhill from there
because I have no plans and I don't have
kids and I don't have a husband and I
don't have errands to run I can go to
the grocery store and learn how to make
shakshuka so that's on my agenda today
also on my agenda probably a re-watch of
some Real Housewives of New York I'm
also doing a re-watch of normal people
on Hulu which is really spicy and I
highly recommend weirdly I'm into this
documentary on Netflix about Blue Zone
countries so I've got a pretty stack day
anyway I say all this to say whenever
I'm hard on myself about why I'm not
married and I don't have kids and I
should be further along at 29 almost 30.
I wouldn't want to do anything else this
Saturday and I know that you can do all
these things when you have kids and
you're married and I understand but the
effortlessness and ease of my life just
kind of focusing on myself and the shack
shook I want to make or the Beyonce
concert I want to go to really pays off
when I'm hard on myself for not being
where Society tells me I should be in
life okay I have even putting the
shakshuka aside I have basically nothing
but sympathy for this woman because we
all have friends who are like this woman
some some Among Us listening right now
might be in the same spot which is
you got duped by Society our entire
culture told you to put off getting
married don't have kids just focus on
your career get an endless series of
degrees don't go to church don't believe
in anything above yourself life is about
nothing more than binging Netflix and
traveling around the world and having
fun experiences and going to brunch
that's what our culture tells people
from the age of
I don't know I guess from in the womb
all the way up until the Music Stops all
the way up until thing the brunches stop
being quite so tasty and the Real
Housewives reruns stop being so
interesting and the shakshuka stops
being so satisfying to make so I have
total sympathy for her and if she were
merely trying to say that while her eyes
and the tone of her voice and the Very
fact that she's pleading for attention
on social media shows that she's
obviously not totally happy and she does
wish that she were married and she does
wish she had kids but it hasn't happened
yet and so she's going to Bear her
difficulties with resignation until
things turn around
I wouldn't even bring it up the problem
here is that she is she is exalting the
very things that make people miserable
and it's because of a misunderstanding
of joy and a misunderstanding of Earthly
happiness which we'll get to in one
second you know they say that money
can't buy happiness but it can make you
secure to have the material things so
that you can pursue happiness and when
you want to be materially secure you
gotta check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 Vladimir Putin
called the US Dollars drop in dominance
objective and no objective and
irreversible
it's not a great Russian Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa formally
have agreed to use local currencies in
trade instead of the US dollar as demand
for the dollar weakens the buying power
of the dollar weakens this is why Birch
gold is busier than ever investors and
Savers are looking to harness the power
of physical gold sheltered in attacks
sheltered Ira you can protect your IRA
or 401K by diversifying with gold from
Birch gold as the U.S dollar continues
to receive pressure from foreign
countries digital currency and central
banks arm yourself with information on
how to protect your savings learn if
gold is right for you too text Knowles
kwles to 98 9898 they will send you a
free info kit on gold with an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews I trust
Birch gold to help you diversify into
gold if a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it will be nice to
have some gold to depend upon text
Knowles Canada 98 98 98 George Bernard
Shaw had a very good line which is
that hell
is the place where you have nothing to
do but amuse yourself
George Bernard show is a socialist
atheist playwright and he was wrong
about a great many things but even when
he was wrong he would he would have
these piercing moments of insight in a
lot of his plays GK Chesterton the great
conservative Catholic author he was
friends with with Shaw and this this is
one of my favorite lines from Shaw and
even the whole context of this line is
even better than the the single phrase
itself it comes from a scene called an
act of a of a play called Don Juan in
hell
and the play is Man and Superman and
a woman Anna says these devils are
mocking me I had better pray and the
statue consoling her says no no no my
child do not pray if you do you will
throw away the main advantage of this
place they're in hell
written over the gate here are the words
leave every hope behind ye who enter
which is a line shall borrowed from
Dante only think what a relief that is
for what is Hope a form of moral
responsibility here in Hell there is no
hope and consequently no Duty no work
nothing to be gained by praying nothing
to be lost by doing what you like hell
in short is a place where you have
nothing to do but amuse yourself at this
moment Don Juan sighs deeply
this is why people who retire
often don't live very long
some people have a great retirement but
the people I've noticed who have a great
retirement are the people who
find a purpose in retirement maybe the
purpose is to manage their family maybe
the purpose is to get involved
politically maybe the purpose is to take
up a new hobby or to join a group or to
write your Memoir or to investigate
genealogy or to play in the family
reunion but the people who just in
retirement go out and decide they're
gonna
hang out they often don't make it very
long they drink too much they get
depressed we all get depressed why
because happiness is not just receiving
passive Pleasures happiness our good
buddy Uncle Aristotle noted about 2400
years ago is excellent rational activity
in accordance with virtue so happiness
involves activity and it's activity done
very well and it's that activity that is
rational it's not totally irrational
activity like going out and I don't know
doing a bunch of drugs and making a
nuisance of yourself and worshiping
Idols in the desert is a rational
activity that is in accordance with
virtue that's what's going to make us
happy what that woman is describing is
broadly true when you don't have kids
you get to wake up late you get to watch
whatever TV shows you want you get to
make shakshuka
if if that is something that one would
want to do you get to go out and drink
too much you get to go to the whatever
concert you want to go to and that will
make you depressed and this is why you
there are skyrocketing rates of
depression and anxiety it's no
coincidence that his marriage rates
plummet as childbirth rates plummet the
rates of anxiety and depression are
increasing because brunch is not
actually that fun it's not fun for a
long time so I don't mean to just scold
this woman I don't mean to mock her in
any way but it is
it is very dangerous for people who is a
self-defense mechanism or a coping
mechanism decide that they're going to
exalt the behaviors that make everybody
miserable that's a dangerous thing the
first step to fixing the problem and
individuals in society broadly have a
lot of problems right now the first step
is admitting that you have a problem and
in in this case the problem is that the
Beyonce concert and staying out too late
and drinking and staying in your bed all
day the and even eating shakshuka as as
your race on datra those are not the
activities of happy joyful people those
are the kind of things that depressants
do depressives drink too much and they
stay in bed all day and they're listless
and they kind of wander around and they
they're just not full of joy so if we
want to turn that around you've got to
put that bad advice aside stop coping
recognize there's a problem and then fix
it you can fix it man
or you don't need to stay in bed all day
and listen to Beyonce and eat chakshuka
speaking of social bonds
truth social might be going the way of
the dodo true social is Trump's
alternative to Twitter and uh truth
social
was begun back in October of 2021 and
now it might collapse within days and it
might collapse because
Trump media and Technology Group which
is the parent company for True social
was going to merge with digital world
acquisition corporation which is a
miami-based company
and they they were then going to go
public via a SPAC a SPAC is a special
purpose acquisition company and anyway
this is all sort of bunch of background
business blah blah blah but the upshot
is the two companies had between 12 and
18 months to complete the merger the
deadline has been extended at least five
times it's now scheduled for September
5th
shareholder meeting is scheduled I
suspect Trump doesn't want to keep true
social around anymore because I think
Trump wants to go back to Twitter now
known as X because that's the way that
he's going to reach the most people but
what happens then what happens if truth
social collapses is this good for Trump
is this bad for Trump
I think basically it would be good for
Trump and I think it would be good for
Trump because one he can now save face
since Elon bought Twitter
the point of Truth social was to give
conservatives an alternative in social
media the libs controlled all of social
media so here's an alternative well then
Elon Musk spent 44 billion bucks and
bought Twitter and has made Twitter much
more amenable to conservatives and has
defended the right of conservatives to
speak on Twitter and is now potentially
even suing left-wing activist groups
that are trying to to pressure
advertisers to defund Twitter you know
he's really put his money where our
mouths are so Trump can say face and say
look the thing that I wanted to
accomplish with through social has now
been accomplished through Elon Musk so
I'm going back
to Twitter I mean the the basic reason
that Trump started true social was that
he was de-platformed he was kicked off
of all these Services even when he was
the sitting president of the United
States well now he's been invited back
on and that is largely thanks to Elon
Musk so he can say look mission
accomplished right but what about the
the
black mark on his record here
Trump is going to be called a failure
because truth social was a failure
I don't think that matters and I
especially don't think that matters to
Trump
Trump has failed at many many things and
I say this with love and admiration he
failed at the Vodka he failed at the
stakes he failed at the airplanes he he
failed it a lot man I'm not even getting
into what happened when he was president
Trump is also one of the most successful
people on planet Earth
that's undeniable I know the Trump
haters want to deny that this man is
extremely successful if you fly around
in a gigantic jumbo jet for your entire
adult life you're a success if you get
yourself elected president the first
time that you really officially try it
you're a big success if you manage to
arouse the ire of America's enemies
abroad and the enemies within the the
Deep State apparatchics who consistently
tried to undermine his campaign in his
presidency you're a success man you've
actually done something are these in
opposition no not at all
the most successful people I know
have also failed more than just about
anybody I know
and it's this is a really important
lesson if you ever want to succeed in
life
successful people tend to fail at more
things than their critics ever even try
and pride which is the queen of vice and
the deadliest of the seven deadly sins
Pride talks in our ear and says hey
don't do this thing you might fail at it
so don't even try just it'll be so
humiliating if you it'll be such a wound
to your pride if you if you try and fail
at something
successful people just ignore that voice
and just try things and they often will
throw spaghetti at the wall think about
how many
how many companies Trump has failed at
or Elon Musk has failed at or
I don't know any of the successful
people on planet Earth
if you go military leaders the failed
military campaigns for goodness sakes
Winston Churchill had he died before the
second world war would have died a
colossal failure but he just kept going
this is true of every great Statesman
throughout history and business leader
and just anybody who's ever done
anything
a really important lesson to take away
it's one of the best lessons from
Trump's public life and look maybe he's
going to fail in the 2024 race I don't
know but the one thing I'm damn sure of
is that he's gonna try and the only way
that he's possibly going to be
successful the only way that you or any
of us is possibly going to be successful
at anything is if we risk failure don't
don't worry about failure
successful people are going to fail more
than than the losers ever even try
speaking of not trying
Joe Biden is not even trying
to go visit East Palestine Ohio do you
remember this was some months ago now
our new Cycles fast or our memories our
attention spans or that of a fruit fly
there was that major train derailment
and chemical spill that poisoned this
town in Ohio
and Biden barely even wanted to mention
it Trump shows up there JD Vance the
senator from Ohio conservative shows up
there demand says why won't Joe Biden
show up here and Joe Biden finally came
out and promised he said okay I'm gonna
go to East Palestine Ohio
well now here we are months and months
later Joe still hasn't shown up here's
his excuse
I said in March that you would go to
East Palestine Ohio you came here how
come you never going to
need well I haven't had the occasion to
go to East Palestine there's a lot going
on here and I just haven't been able to
break I was thinking whether I'd go to
East Palestine this week but I've then
was reminded I've got to go literally
around the world I'm going from uh from
Washington to India to Vietnam to and so
I it's going to be a while but uh we're
making sure that East Palestine has what
they need materially in order to deal
with their problems
his excuse as to why he hasn't visited
this troubled American town that was the
site of a major
corporate and government crime let's
call it what it is just an absolute
negligence and incompetence at least so
egregious that it poisoned this whole
town and his excuses well I can't go
there because I gotta go literally
everywhere else on Earth before I go
there I've got to go anywhere else
anywhere and everywhere else than this
town in America Joe Biden cares so
little about East Palestine Ohio that in
the months since that spill he hasn't
even learned how to pronounce the name
of the town
he's made plenty of time to go visit
Kiev oh he can go visit Kiev just fine
and Vietnam and this place in that place
he just can't visit this troubled
American Town Joe Biden can spend 382
days on vacation Joe Biden has spent 40
percent four zero percent of his
presidency on vacation just doesn't have
that time to visit East Palestine
a more perfect example of how little our
ruling class cares about America I have
not seen a widening of the gulf between
the elites and the actual American
people
and a promise
that populism will continue
from the ruling class the beatings will
continue until morale improves and from
the now mostly the Republican party but
a little bit on the on the left too uh
the populism is going to continue as our
political order becomes so decadent
decays so much in the social bonds just
collapse between the rulers and the
ruled now one little luxury here that
all of us no matter how put upon we are
by our liberal Elite uh can enjoy is
delicious good ranchers right now go to
goodranches.com use code nulls I don't
know about you but this summer heat in
Nashville felt hotter than a two dollar
pistol and that's because of the
inflation
we're feeling that heat in more ways
than one these days the thing that I'm
not sweating though is my meat price
thanks to good ranchers my price is
locked in for two years and you might be
thinking a price lot guarantee on meat
yeah it's amazing I don't know how they
do it it doesn't make any sense with
inflation and everything and especially
that their price is already quite low
for meat that is much higher quality
than anything you're getting at the
grocery store or any other service right
now it's just the greatest their
hamburgers are the best I've ever had
the steaks are absolutely out of this
world the New York strip in particular I
love the rib eye is excellent I just had
the other day they've got pork now
they've got chicken they've got
everything I couldn't possibly recommend
this company enough their meat is all
100 American
Steakhouse quality just amazing
goodranches.com right now use code
Knowles for 30 bucks off any box promo
code Knowles Canada wlas
goodrantchers.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
speaking of foreign places France has
just prepared to enforce a ban on Muslim
dress in schools
so this would be the Abaya on women you
know where you can barely see any of the
women and this would be the I forget the
name of the dress for the Muslim men but
that too kaput not allowed to wear that
in French schools anymore and this is a
really good idea not because I don't
like the Muslims I like the Muslims very
much I have a great deal of respect for
the Muslims but because France is France
and France should be allowed to be
France France doesn't need to be Saudi
Arabia and Italy doesn't need to be
Eritrea and America doesn't need to be
Guatemala countries should be allowed to
have their own national identity and
culture and people ought to be able to
Define what that is and engage in their
own traditional practices I read this
book over the weekend
made a little bit of a splash and it was
a book in Italian it hasn't been
translated yet into English and I
thought you know there are so few books
in Italian that ever really seem to make
the news
Dante petrarch Picacho
that's pretty much it you know certain
there's not a ton of of Italian
literature that tends to make it up one
of these books that did is by this
Italian General Roberto venachi it's
called ilmando alcondradio the world
upside down
the point of this book
is that we're living in obviously in an
upside down world
where people are losing their
sovereignty and traditional practices
are being called hateful and evil and
being kicked out of society and bizarre
eccentricities are being placed at the
center of society and the tiny little
minorities of people not even just
racial minorities but like the minority
of this imagined identity group or that
bizarrely inclined
psychosexual identity group uh they get
to dominate and they get to set all of
the rules for all of society and that
this is completely upside down this is a
book that became one of the best-selling
books in Italy over the last year and it
had to be self-published
and that tells you so much
it's a it's a very good thing that
self-publishing is now Advanced enough
that anybody with a manuscript can
upload it to Amazon and have it nailed
out in physical form and it can become a
bestseller that's great
but it's a very bad thing that many
books that are commonsensical that would
become best sellers have to be
self-published because no publisher
would ever take it on
because this book by General venachi
sorry former General venachi he just got
fired for publishing the book
this book by former General venachi was
called racist sexist homophobic this is
dadist that's how you know it's going to
be a good book these days when the
liberal media says racist sexist phobic
this kind of hateful that kind of
hateful you know it's probably going to
be a pretty interesting book
and and his firing for alleged
homophobia proves his point we're now in
the world upside down that you can't
extol a traditional normal Christian
just
just classical conception of family life
without being called a hateful bigot and
losing your job for it even if your job
is to go kill your enemies even if your
job is a really old school manly kind of
job you're going to lose it for that the
the point of the book that I found the
most interesting is when he focuses on
what he calls the dictatorship of
minorities
maybe minorities of immigrant groups
maybe sexual minorities of groups who
identify as whatever whatever sort of
identities I'm not allowed to talk about
on YouTube I think you catch the drift
uh maybe it's a religious minority maybe
it's a cultural minority but the notion
that
even a group that comprises three people
can upend the standards for everybody
Italy is a Catholic country it's about
as Catholic a country as you could
possibly get and yet increasingly Italy
is told from the secular authorities
from the European Union that they can't
have
Christmas displays and celebrations
in public
because you know that's some people
don't celebrate Christmas
some well I guess that's from the vast
majority of people in Italy celebrate
where the vast vast overwhelming
majority celebrate Christmas
so why can't they have their Christmas
celebrations
well
because of the rights of the minorities
and so you see and venachi never refers
to this in the book but what you're
seeing is and and increasing tension
between democracy and liberalism
which we use interchangeably today but
they're actually opposed to one another
the Liberals actually changed the
Wikipedia page for for democracy to say
that democracy is a form of liberalism
liberalism came about a few hundred
years ago democracy has been around for
Millennia okay but liberalism is so
totalitarian it just consumes everything
and brings it into itself and if you
oppose it then you have to be
anti-democratic but that doesn't make
any sense democracy is ruled by the
majority liberalism at its very best is
supposed to be the protection of Rights
of minorities
which can is a fine thing you do want to
protect the the legitimate rights of
minorities but as liberalism has
advanced everything has been called a
right
things that are not rights at all have
been called rights things that we're not
allowed to talk about on YouTube you
know like um
men wearing dresses in public or Pride
parades or all the other sorts of things
that are definitely going to get bleeped
out on YouTube those are not rights
those are wrongs wrong things cannot be
rights and how do we understand rights
we understand rights by by examining
abstract principles of Justice by
examining the natural law by using our
faculties of reason and our moral
conscience to deduce conclusions about
about uh the the good the true and the
Beautiful we can't do that anymore
because we live in a radical skepticism
so we the radical skepticism is impelled
by liberalism which says everybody has
the right to do whatever the hell they
want at any given time and so it becomes
this tyranny of subjectivism this
tyranny of relativism
that now is overwhelming the right of
sovereign states to be their own people
to determine who comes in who who gets
the rights of citizens and how people
live
very very troubling because left to its
own devices liberalism will just erase
these cultures they'll erase the people
they'll erase the Customs they'll erase
the religions they'll relate they'll
it'll erase everything and because
nature aborts a vacuum something else is
going to come in in its place because
everybody's got to serve somebody
so this is this is also why you're
saying increasing populace and this is
why fashionable squishy Republican types
used to make fun of the notion of the
war on Christmas oh those bitter
clinging deplorable idiots that care
about Christmas who cares it's no big
deal just say happy holidays or whatever
no it
if
if we give up Christmas
what are we as a country oh those
deplorable idiots they care about
immigration no stop it just stop being
so racist and xenophobic if we give up
borders what is our country if we give
up
if we give up our practices the people
who make up the nation what we believe
in now increasingly our right to
self-government
what are we
we're nothing
we just become individual consumers
we're just here we we end up exactly
where that poor woman who was pretending
that she's really happy childless and
husbandless at 29. we end up right where
she is which is yeah okay we don't have
any social bonds we don't have any
purpose in life we don't have anything
that we're aiming at we don't have
anything that really gets us out of the
bed in the morning but we do have a
bunch of cheap crap but we do GDP went
up a little bit
we are we are an economic zone well who
cares how stupid do we have to be to
find out that money doesn't actually buy
you happiness and that
we shouldn't worship Mammon
people are so desperate for meaning that
they're going to the desert right now to
take a bunch of drugs and have a bunch
of orgies and worship actual fire idols
and then be washed out and fly because
of that which you know again I don't
want to read too deeply into it but
that's how desperate people are for
meaning okay
so that's the word that is the world
upside down
and you can expect rates of anxiety to
go up prescription drugs for depression
pills to go up you can expect the life
expectancy to continue to decline
because of debts of Despair you can
expect marriage rates to continue to
Plumbing you can expect birth rates to
continue to plummet until we flip that
world back right side up now speaking of
confused people
and things I can't talk about on YouTube
another
young lady went viral
sobbing crying
because
[Music]
you know we have a very exciting offer
coming up for all of our daily wire
members early access to a first look at
the highly anticipated 10-part original
series The Candace Owens convicting a
murderer Early Access to view this
series is September 7th only on daily
wire plus take a look at this teaser
coming up on convicting murderer part of
me don't want to believe that he did
this the blood that was under that back
area was indicative of the head wound my
brother likes to push a lot of people
around I don't give a about
anything I ain't got a listen to nobody
how were these filmmakers able to
convince so many people and the man like
Steven Avery is innocent how many times
did he stab her
once and show me where I hear they gave
him power they're trying to get
everything on there that they get it's
not good for an Avery to have power I
told you all along
that can hurt Stephen I'm not gonna lie
for him no more I can't do it watch
convicting a murderer a new 10-part
series on daily wire Plus
now Early Access to watch convicting a
murderer will be available for daily
wire Plus members on September 7th the
official premiere for convicting
murderer will take place on X that
platform formerly known as Twitter on
September 8th at 9pm Eastern Candace
will be live chatting with special
guests at The X event at 5 PM so head on
over to X to join the conversation full
series will be available only on daily
wear Plus
head on over to daily wire.com subscribe
use code truth
t-r-u-t-h-4 25 off your daily wire Plus
subscription everyone's talking about it
everybody look look it's everywhere okay
Candace's take on this series is really
interesting so do not
miss out and subscribe today my favorite
comment on Friday
is from Junior 3170 who says my late
father told me about the 70s he said it
was hell everything was garbage from the
Cars to the music I couldn't even get
normal Jeans by the end fair enough
and this will impact the presidential
race of course because we are living in
the 1970s we the same sort of economic
problems
energy crises massive inflation
social breakdown
a DC grocery store
Giant grocery store is southeast DC has
removed name brands
from the store it's got generic brands
but no more name brands Advil Colgate
tied it's gone
it's gone because people keep stealing
and the shop owner he says I don't want
to do this I'd like to sell the name
brand products but the reality is that
tide is not a profitable item in this
store because it keeps getting stolen in
many instances people stock the product
and within two hours it's gone so it's
not on the Shelf anyway
you see he's seen theft rise tenfold in
the last five years
this is
literally why we can't have nice things
just even material things we can't have
we sell out all of the Social Capital so
that we can have cheap consumer goods
and the irony of it is we end up without
even the nice consumer goods because
people are stealing so much that they
can't even put them on the shelves
if we cease to be a coherent society as
increasingly is happening and we simply
become individual economic units just
sharing the same space which is the
vision the left has for us and frankly
it's the vision that a lot of the right
has for us too we're just out there we
just care about cutting our taxes and
just making our money and leave me alone
and forget about those social questions
well okay if we're all just individuals
living in the same space then you know
what's going to happen
all the things that keep us behaving
Community shame a sense of a fear of
divine retribution concern for our souls
and our reputation in the community even
the law that's all going to go away and
so what's going to happen is first
there's going to be disorder as we're
seeing now and then almost maybe even
worse than the disorder
there's going to be a miserable kind of
order imposed on us
because this is the point I've made a
number of times before there will be
order
there will be order
the state
will protect itself
so either we can behave ourselves
and act in accordance with virtue and
religion and morality or the state is
going to come in and impose that
but there there will be order eventually
and the the kind of order that's going
to be imposed on us
is going to be a miserable one
because it's going to be a an order
without
the uplift and the inspiration of
religion without the natural bonds of
family which disappear I mean they
disappear in the sense that people just
stop having family they stop getting
married they stop having kids it's going
to be one without tradition we'll have
gotten rid of those Traditions it's
going to be one without a sense of
loyalty to the nation and a bond of
kinship to the people it's just going to
be
a heavy-handed order
of
of sticks and carrots the stick is going
to be increasing punishments from the
government like locking people up for
ordinary basic political dissent as
we're seeing all around us and the
carrot is going to be drugs and
promiscuous sex and
Netflix and
staying out late and drinking and going
to Beyonce concerts and not getting out
of your bed until 10 in the morning
that's
that one of them is George Orwell one of
them is Aldous Huxley one of them is
1984 one of them is Brave New World and
it's not going to be one of the other
you're going to get them both at the
same time do you want do you want that
to be your Society no
well then
we've got to have the other stuff the
tradition and the coherence among the
people
and the religion and the
end of being normal
and that's what we're going to have to
have now I teased you
I teach you earlier I said that we were
going to get to kovid and fauci
I'm going to leave this as a little bit
of a tease for tomorrow but
all I'll say for now is you've seen The
Masks start to come back in Hollywood
Lionsgate instituted a mask mandate
Morris Brown College in Atlanta Rutgers
University bringing the masks back oh
just a couple weeks to slow the spread
you're seeing New York saying if you're
in public maybe now start to wear the
masks Jill Biden's apparently come down
with covid how she knows I don't know
why people still test for this
ridiculous
uh ailment I don't know
well I do know it's because of the 2024
election but
fauci is starting to come back on TV but
the twist here is
CNN
is taking Dr fauci to task for being
wrong why is that what's going on
what do the lips have up their sleeves
we'll get to that tomorrow because right
now we've got to get to the member block
the rest of the show continues now I
know it's Tuesday
but we didn't have music Monday because
that was Labor Day so
what Professor Jacob has said in his
dubious wisdom
is that today we're not going to have
Tuesday
we're going to have
music Monday on Tuesday and then
tomorrow for woke Wednesday we're going
to lump in Tuesday and woke Wednesday
together in one day and then theology
Thursday and then fake headline Friday
I'm my head is spinning just thinking
about it the rest of the show continues
now you do not want to miss it become a
member use code Knowles Canada wlas a
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
foreign
[Music]